et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois el bacha économie fondateur de
libnanews bonsoir bonsoir mâcha merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france le liban qui a donc signé un
accord on vient d'entendre avec la
jordanie pour l'acheminement
d'électricité via la syrie est ce un
réel espoir pour parler pallier aux
pénuries du pays où c'est l'illustration
de d'une misère extrême
dans lequel est plongée désormais liban
bonsoir tout d'abord c'est pas une c'est
une solution temporaire c'est pas une
solution pérenne
205 ses 250 mégas watts le jour c'est
150 mégawatts cela nuit sachant qu'en
fait le liban
nécessiterait 3000 mégawatts c'est
qu'actuellement la production
disponibles des causses 2 500 méga watts
ça veut dire que même si on ajoute 250
mégawatts on reste très largement
déficitaire il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
solution
réelle à
au problème de l'électricité ensuite cet
accord doit se doubler d'un autre accord
enfin d'une taille ou d'une autre
solution qui est l'importation de gaz
égyptien à destination de la centrale de
deir al mare des rames à rousseau au
nord du liban qui rajouterait 450
mégawatts on resterait toujours
déficitaire au niveau de la production
donc la solution à long terme ce n'est
pas l'importation d'électricité c'est
pas le gazoduc en tant que tel c'est
aussi augmenté localement la production
d'électricité en mettant en place de
nouvelles structures et non plus des
centrales qui sont obsolètes et dont le
coût d'exploitation sont très
importantes et qui sont aussi à
l'origine de la problématique du déficit
de l'edf qui coûte 2 milliards de
dollars de prêts par an qui coûtait
avant par dont deux milliards de dollars
par an au liban
la banque mondiale en tout cas donné son
accord de principe armées elles
conditionnent quand même cet accord à
une hausse du prix du kilowatt des
mesures liées notamment à la
transparence la lutte contre la
corruption et la restructuration du
secteur est ce que le libre en est
capable d'accéder à ses exigences
techniquement
ce sont des choses qui sont déjà très
dur à mettre en place parce que la
hausse du prix du kilowatt on est en
situation de crise économique ça va être
très dur pour la population d'accepter
un kilowatt à 2000 livres quand il coûte
à le voir actuel de 200 livres
même si
en temps dollars ça diminue le pouvoir
d'achat pour un fortement été dégradée
ces deux dernières années
d'autre part l'électricité est un sujet
politique sensible où il ya eu beaucoup
d'interactions politique d'ingérence
politique et il ya eu beaucoup de
corruption de la part de tous les partis
on se souvient que dans les années 90 il
ya eu une histoire il ya eu un échec par
exemple d'adn appel d'offres visant à
construire une centrale électrique parce
que y avait une histoire d'une
commission de 50 millions de dollars on
a eu des histoires de barrage et ainsi
de suite dans les années 2000 et donc
c'est un sujet très sensible où il ya
une d'ingérence politique
oui les affaires de corruption étaient
encore dernièrement sur l'importation de
fioul on a découvert des histoires de
commissions illégales et de fioul qui
était en fait frelaté qui correspondait
pas au cahier des charges
autre fait de la semaine au liban non de
moindre à une figure symbole de la
politique libanaise a quitté la vie
politique saad hariri s'est pas
seulement le premier ministre libanais
mais celle héritée d'une grande famille
politique au liban alors lui s'est
justifié en évoquant la la forte
influence iranienne les relations
internationales et les divisions
internes que 10 ce départ selon vous
et pas seulement l'influencent iranienne
est aussi un manque de soutien des pays
arabes
saad hariri ne bénéficie plus en tant
que tel de la pluie de l'appui de
de l'arabie saoudite et
il ya des preuves personnes proches à
lui qui ont dit que lui même ou réadmis
que l'arabie saoudite n'était plus prêt
à financer sa campagne électorale
aujourd'hui pour les prochaines
élections législatives
donc il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui
engendrent en vo
toute la campagne de 2009 par exemple a
coûté un milliard de dollars à certaines
puissances pour permis pour financer des
partis locaux
en tout cas son son départ intervient
dans un contexte d'effondrement
économique évidemment la banque mondiale
a d'ailleurs qualifié cette situation
comme l'une des plus graves jamais
observées dans le monde
comment vous ce pays va faire ce pour se
remettre et qui a aujourd'hui les
épaules pour prendre la place de saad
hariri
tout d'abord
c'est pas les politiques en fin de
compte qui les tiennent
réellement le pouvoir aujourd'hui dans
ce pays à ce qu'on appelle le parti des
banques c'est ce parti des banques
aujourd'hui qui fait la pluie et le beau
temps au niveau économique donc c'est
eux qui ont fait chuter l'ancien
gouvernement à sindia parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord sur le chiffrage
des pertes du secteur bancaire est
encore aujourd'hui on voit très bien
comment ils ont mis en place le premier
ministre qui lui même actionnaire de
bank donc la relance de l'économie
libanaise ça va déprendre de
l'acceptation par ce parti des banques
du chiffrage des pertes du secteur
bancaire est autant qu'on sache ils vont
faire porter le chapeau en majorité aux
déposants puisqu'on évoque des pertes
supportées par les déposants à hauteur
de 55% contre seulement 19% pour les
actionnaires des banques
le libéralisme et la diminution du
justement d'aider les estimations des
pertes du secteur bancaire va amener
probablement une diminution des
exigences possibles pour le liban par
rapport à l'aide internationale
le précédent gouvernement souhaitait 10
milliards de dollars du fmi aujourd'hui
on évoque près de 4 milliards de dollars
et c sont des sommes qui sont totalement
insuffisants pour relancer l'économie
libanaise puisque le gouverneur de la
banque du liban évoque lui-même
un chiffre de 12,7 à 15 milliards de
dollars qui seraient nécessaires
d'autres figures et un dernière et vos
cachets de 23 milliards de dollars donc
la solution aujourd'hui n'est pas
politique c'est aussi dans le déblocage
et la reconnaissance et l'arrêt du déni
de ses intérêts économiques et pour
pouvoir aller faire des choses dont nous
parlait tout à l'heure du problème de
l'électricité aujourd'hui le problème de
l'électricité c'est qu'on n'arrive plus
à financer la mise en place de
l'électricité on a des effondrements des
services publics d'effondrement des
services téléphoniques
qu'à beyrouth la solide à deux semaines
qui ne marchaient plus faute de fioul on
à l'effondrement aujourd'hui des réseaux
de distribution d'eau à des routes et
dans les temps les prix ont joint
alentours justement parce que c'est par
ces personnes bas bloc en quelque sorte
tous toute possibilité d' aide
internationale et de conclusion rapide
des négociations avec le fmi merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous françois
el bacha nous avons apporté votre
décryptage ce soir